[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle émission consacrée au débat
pour les élections législatives dimanche
prochain près de 70 mille électeurs sont
appelés à choisir leurs députés parmi 14
candidats pour la 12e circonscription
des yvelines pour ce débat neuf d'entre
eux ont répondu à notre invitation pour
des raisons pratiques évidemment nous
avons scindé cette émission en deux
parties à distinctes les mêmes thèmes
seront abordés à chaque fois et pour
cette première séquence je suis en
plateau avec marie noëlle bas candidate
socialiste sophie cain candidat
suppléant de david douillet le député
sortant investi par les républicains
élus dei en toile barreau candidat de la
france insoumise jean luc le gall et
candidat du front national et fabien
mais tu es candidat de debout la france
bonsoir à tous les cinq ans par quelques
précisions avant de commencer ce débat
vous avez évidemment le droit d'échanger
entre vous
durant cette émission votants paroles
seront contées attention donc penser à
gérer votre temps
je voulais indiquerait aussi plusieurs
fois pendant l'émission première
question qu'on le pose compose à tous
les candidats lors de chaque débat
pourquoi les électeurs doivent t'ils
vous faire confiance
on commence avec vous marie noëlle bas
pour le parti socialiste pourquoi les
électeurs doivent t'ils voté pour vous
notamment dimanche prochain et bien
parce que je suis une femme de gauche
une femme de conviction par
l'opportuniste
je n'ai pas changé de camp je soutiens
les idées novatrices de benoît hamon
depuis près de 10 ans maintenant je suis
militante féministe je lutte depuis
toujours pour la solidarité la justice
l'égalité la culture pour toutes et tous
et puis surtout contre les violences que
notre société fait aux femmes notamment
les inégalités salariales les
difficultés pour les gardes d'enfants
l'après corps et de la précarisation
mais aussi la société fait des violences
aux hommes notamment violence au travail
et c'est en influant en fait sur les
lois que l'on peut combattre
efficacement ces inégalités et ces
violences j'ai toujours accepté le débat
contrairement à certains manifestement
qui ne veulent pas qu'ils ne veulent pas
venir mais je suis aussi prêt à voter
des lois qui me paraît très intéressante
pour le bien de tous de la communauté
des françaises et des français sophie
ten la question variés un petit peu
pourquoi les électeurs doivent t'ils
refaire confiance à david douillet
dimanche prochain alors avant de vous
répondre je lui paie d'abord excuser son
absence auprès de vous tous il est en ce
moment même à goupillière en train
d'animer une réunion publique sera 20
heures à orgeval
on a randomisé 23 régions dont 23
communes de la circonscription afin de
permettre à chaque habitant de venir
nous rencontrer s'ils le souhaitaient
les élections législatives c'est avant
tout une élection locale et nous paraît
important de connaître les candidats et
les candidates qui se cache derrière les
étiquettes politiques
alors pour revenir à votre question je
vois trois raisons le premier c'est le
renouvellement politique risque de vous
étonner
ce n'est pas parce que on n'est pas
novice en politique qu'on est bon à
jeter à la poubelle
david il a passé 30 ans dans la vie
civile en tant que sportif chacun le
sait mais également comme chef
d'entreprise pendant dix ans comme
parrain d'une grande association
caritative de pièces jaunes
et c'est cette richesse qui va se mettre
au service de son mandat politique
deuxième chose le travail de terrain si
la majorité des élus la 12e
circonscription des yvelines d'un porte
aujourd'hui son soutien
c'était pas anodin je pense à karl olive
le maire de poissy joséphine kossmann
berger maire de plaisir
adriano ballarin maire de crespières
fabienne devèze mai
rabiller alandry qu'olmert de ben
troisième chose
l'expérience je pense que dans le
contexte politique actuel il est bon de
pouvoir compter sur des équipes
expérimentées qui seront en capacité
d'agir des lendemains leur élection
antoine barreau pour la france insoumise
pourquoi les électeurs doivent t'ils
vous faire confiance
écoutez d'abord parce que je représente
la france insoumise qui est un mouvement
qui représente véritablement là là une
vraie force de gauche qui est à mon avis
la seule qui est capable de s'opposer au
gouvernement actuel le gouvernement
actuel c'est un gouvernement qui se veut
donc et tout cas qui se dit ni de droite
ni de gauche
et pourtant qui est composé
essentiellement de gens qui viennent de
la droite est pour beaucoup aussi de
socialistes qui sont particulièrement
numéro et si il faut s'il doit y avoir
une véritable opposition et qu'elle soit
de gauche et il faut donc voter pour la
france insoumise et je représente ce
mouvement qui a mis au point un
programme qui n'est pas un programme qui
a été fait de circonstance à l'invite
qui a été modifié ce programme a été
édité d'ailleurs vous pouvez le voir il
a été édité en 2016
donc il a été travaillé et c'est sur la
base de ce programme que les électeurs
vont de décider de l'élection de la
france s'est arrêté du représentant de
la france à soubise en ce qui me
concerne
alors bien sûr je suis pas attention
votre temps de parole à continuer mais
je veux juste indiqué que désiré c'est
pour que je dirais que je n'ai pas
d'expérience d'hommes politiques mais
j'ai une expérience je suis un ancien
cadre supérieur qui tient de la finance
donc je sais ce que c'est qu'un budget
je sais ce que c'est qu'un déficit et
j'ai toujours au cours de ma carrière
essayer de mettre l'humain au centre de
mes actions et je continuerai à le faire
on poursuit avec jean le gall est pour
le front national même question soit
alors moi je n'aurai qu'un seul parti
capable d'être nos positions au
président actuel comme une opposition
l'est pas et constructive et les
passants négative mais souley le
programmes des manuels macron fait froid
dans le dos et le sol parti démocratique
et républicain le seul parti patriote
avec un pourcentage devrait important
c'est le front national et donc on est
le seul à pouvoir faire barrage je
dirais à l'analyse total sur l'assemblée
nationale que souhaite
emmanuel macron et je pense que c'est
important qu'il ne véritable opposition
si les sondages on voit tellement donne
effectivement près de 400 députés pour
macron ce serait une catastrophe pour la
france et je crois qu'il faut surtout
qu'il n'est pas une majorité absolue et
autres poules et à la plus faible
possible
enfin on termine avec fabien était pour
debout la france pourquoi les électeurs
doivent t'ils vous faire confiance
dimanche à voter pour des candidats
double affront c'est voter pour des
candidats courageux quoi je vais aussi
développer l'intérêt supérieur de la
nation jeudi courageux parce qu'en fait
nous sommes les seuls à avoir osé se
rapproprier des thèmes qui ont été
abordés abandonné successivement par la
droite et par la gauche à savoir le
peuple une nation la souveraineté le bon
sens la critique la critique dans
l'union européenne
les frontières la sécurité tous ces
thèmes là qu'ils ont été abandonnés
successivement par la droite et par la
gauche ont été ont été récupérés par le
front national du coup nous on a eu lieu
au courage de revenir sur ces sujets là
qui sont des sujets très importants
néanmoins nous allons quand même une
différence enfin plusieurs différences
majeures avec le front national
nous avons dit gestion sérieuse des
sujets et des dossiers nous n'avons pas
la même histoire que le front national
est notre rapport avec la presse est
plus apaisé on va dire pour être poli
c'est fini pour vous c'est fini merci à
25 pour vos réponses or on poursuit avec
le premier thème est le thème principal
de cette émission le développement
économique le chômage le pouvoir d'achat
sont forcément des priorités pour les
français la courbe du chômage semble
enfin commencer à s'inverser
alors si vous êtes élue députée d'ici
une dizaine de jours quelle proposition
de loi vous porterez pour soutenir cette
inversion de la courbe du chômage
sophie calle
les républicains souhaitent notamment si
je me réfère au programme l aer
supprimée et baisser les charges qui
pèsent sur le travail et la production
vous pensez à quel type de charge
précisément via l'impôt sur le revenu
moi je voulais dire un mot par rapport à
ce qui est en train d'être proposé en ce
moment par l'actuel gouvernement
david il a été très clair il est il
votre à toutes les lois qui concourront
au développement économique à la
création de richesse la création
d'emplois pourquoi parce que la lutte
contre le chômage c'est la priorité
numéro un dans ce pays
et moi je voulais aussi en profiter pour
vous donner trois exemples concrets de
ce qu un député peut faire pour agir
concrètement que développement
économique de son territoire à poissy on
a une grande usine qui s'appelle psa il
ya quelques années elles étaient
fortement menacées et david douillet a
bataillé il a bataillé pour que l'état
le gouvernement et notamment le ministre
du redressement productif de l'époque
arnaud montebourg investissent dans le
groupe aujourd'hui on voit que ce groupe
ait été sorti des difficultés et
commence à nouveau à se développer
deuxième exemple le rer eole en savez
ces holdings qui valide la défense à
mantes la jolie en 2015 son financement
était fille était menacé par un rapport
le rapport du rond sans l'intervention
de david et d'un certain nombre d'élus
de ce territoire dont le président du
conseil départemental pierre bédier
aujourd'hui on ne pourrait pas voir le
rer e eole à l'horizon 2020 deuxième
exemple
troisième exemple psg c'est david qui a
milité dès le départ pour que le nouveau
centre d'entraînement du psg s'installe
à poissy pourquoi est ce que c'est un
vecteur de développement et
d'attractivité pour territoire puis
c'est aussi un vecteur d'emplois et
quand on sait que ce projet sera situé à
proximité immédiate de des zones
urbaines et plusieurs difficultés de la
ville que sont la coudraie et beauregard
voilà des exemples très concrets de ce
qu un député peut faire pour son
territoire je précise juste que quand
vous parlez de david évidemment vous
faites référence à rêves celui des
douilles et jean-luc galets
si l'on se réfère au programme
présidentiel de marine le pen il y a le
souhait notamment de baisser les charges
mais seulement pour les tpe pme
est-ce que vous pouvez préciser
seulement est peut-être un peu exagéré
mais effectivement de baisser les
charges sur les petites et moyennes
entreprises voire les très petites
entreprises
également on est ainsi intervenu au
niveau du rsa donc sous lé là
aujourd'hui les entreprises croulent
sous les charges mais en plus des
charges
souvent ces petites entreprises sont
sous traitantes d'entreprises plus
grosses qui les étrangle par des
conditions financières des prix qu'il
avait chez d'année en année chaque fois
que des délais de règlement
celle au calendes grecques c'est 90 120
jours 150 jours dans certains cas là que
la loi prévoit en autre chose et donc
sous les six entreprises ont souvent
conséquents du mal à se remettre
je dirais des commandes qu'il reçoit des
gros donneurs d'ordres et ça
effectivement il faut aider les
entreprises car associons de petites
entreprises qui embauchent et qu'on
regarde les emplois à fait dans la notre
société très peu de grosses entreprises
ont augmenté leurs effectifs et cinq des
dix dernières années ce sont
essentiellement les pme qui créent de
l'emploi et donc et dont les pme
c'est là que se trouve le pôle d'emploi
et baisser les charges ou bien sûr les
jeunes non plus plus court à leur antre
des paiements plus court bien évidemment
au niveau des donneurs d'ordres est
fabien était debout la france agit en
soit âgé aussi pour les tpe pme avec
vous c zéro taxe et 0 normes
supplémentaires ça veut dire dans ce cas
là qui a pas forcément d'allègement
c'est juste pas plus oui effectivement
et surtout pour le coup je rejoins
jean luc guerrier c'est nous souhaitons
soutenir les pme tpe qu'ils et elles
sont productrices de d'emploi et j'ai un
très génératrice de richesses
contrairement aux multinationales qui
peuvent enfin qui délocalisent dekalb le
peuvent
malgré les profits kalfon mais on va
encore plus loin que parce qu'en fait
aux états unis il ya déjà des lois qui
le permette à l'état de garantir le
marché public une partie de marchés
publics aux pme et tpe locale enfin
nationale et nous souhaitons justement
réservé 75% du marché public au tmp tpe
et pme françaises pour les fascine c'est
aussi une façon de les soutenir et en
fait on doit aussi encore plus loin là
en parlant d'économie on souhaite
revenir sur la directive des
travailleurs détachés qui est une
directive immoral et aberrante aussi
directive européenne rappelle
effectivement effectivement que macro on
ne peut pas à remettre en cause
justement nous on souhaite juste
enfin on souhaite la supprimer tout
simplement parce qu'en fait il ya une
double in inégalités avec cette
directive
c'est que d'une les travailleurs
étrangers payent leurs charges sociales
dans leur pays d'origine
du coup ça mais les france en
concurrence enfin ça mais la france est
en concurrence avec des gens qui
respectent pas les mêmes normes et de
deux les charges sociales sont payés
dans les pays d'origine sont pas payés
en france
du coup ça fait un manque à gagner pour
l'état du coup cette mesure permettrait
à la fois de créer de l'emploi et de
récupérer de l'argent
marie noëlle besse vous aviez fini vous
aviez fini marie noëlle bas le ps a
défini 22 points pour ces élections
on y retrouve une proposition que des
candidats pourraient sûrement soutenir
ici le développement du fabriqué en
france par une loi qui rêverait 50% des
marchés publics aux pme et tpe donc vous
aussi c'est les pme et les tpe
bien sûr il est évident aussi que le
la plupart des salariés sont dans les
pme et dans les tpe
mais je pense aussi qu'il est très
important d'avoir une politique
d'innovation d'investissement dans la
r&d et d'investissements dans la haute
technologie de façon à faire émerger des
talents qu'on a en france avec nos avec
nos écoles
et puis également de lancer des grands
travaux de rénovation énergétique dans
le parc immobilier est également parmi
les grands travaux il faudrait faire
travailler dans les énergies
renouvelables puisque il y à aussi et
non un champ une ouverture très
importantes sur ces énergies
renouvelables qui pourraient à terme
offrir énormément d'emplois
antoine barreau sur le développement
économique vous avez un petit peu
d'avancé donc comme vous voulez vous
gérez votre temps de parole jean luc
mélenchon indiqué dans son programme
présidentiel qu'il était possible de
créer 3 5 millions d'emplois notamment à
travers la transition énergétique vous
en parliez à l'instant
du coup quelques est le projet de loi
pourrait voir le jour avec vous oui je
vais répondre un instant j'avais déjà
répondre à notre ami rentes et
républicains parce que là le
développement économique ne se borne pas
simplement à notre département
d'ailleurs c'est un des départements les
plus riches de
de france à dire avant le 2 sept oui
alors c'est donc oui oui je comprends je
comprends mais il faut que l'adhésion de
la france alors il faut d'abord partir
d'un constat c'est que le gouvernement
actuel et même chez les républicains
quand on voit le probable de monsieur
fillon qui était un programme drastique
il voulait supprimer 500 mille emplois
au point de france maf il faut les
attentions lui veut supprimer 120 mille
postes de fonctionnaires il veut
répondre favorablement aux diktats qui
veut respecter le diktat de l'union
européenne qui est de d'avoir un déficit
de 3% alors c'est cool peut-être les
propositions de la bourse alors vous
poussez vous avez une majorité le
disposer de justement redevenu de lancer
le programme de rénovation écologique en
développant tout ce qui est énergie qui
ne sera pas à l'utilisation de deux
fossiles fermer le nul face à fermer
définitivement les centrales atomiques
et je dirais lancer un programme
d'investissement qui dansera qui
relancera le lan ploie est également en
augmentant les salaires relancer la
consommation
voilà voilà on va voir vos temps de
parole était vont s'afficher dans
quelques instants on va voir qu'il ya
déjà des écarts importants entre vous on
va les voir s'afficher dans quelques
secondes
justement il arrive voilà ces temps de
parole du coup antoine barreau je vous
le disais sofica elle aussi un petit peu
d'avancé
je voulais aborder un deuxième point qui
en lien avec le développement économique
avec vous et qui vous permettra
peut-être de réguler ces temps de parole
vos idées pour soutenir le commerce de
proximité en qualité de député c'est un
moyen aussi que vous pouvez avoir
on sait les difficultés notamment dans
les zones rurales face aux grandes
structures commerciales des grandes
entreprises
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire marie
noëlle bas c'est vous qui avaient le
plus de retard pour le commerce de
proximité à les commerces de proximité
extrêmement important parce que
justement il s'adresse à des gens qui
n'ont pas forcément de voiture ou qui ne
peuvent pas forcément prendre le bus
donc qui font leurs courses au quotidien
c'est essentiel de le protéger c'est
essentiel de le protéger dans les
centres villes notamment
comme vous devez le savoir moi je suis
plutôt contre le travail le dimanche
parce que je trouve peu il faut c'est
une histoire philosophique il faut un
jour dans lequel n'est pas de
consumérisme
donc je pense qu'il faut
essayez de donner le plus possible
d'ouverture danser dans ses magasins de
proximité et
essayez de permettre aux gens d'avoir
des navettes pour y aller et pouvoir se
garer dans l'est dans les villes de
façon facile
jean-luc galets pour le front national
on sait que c'était souvent un point mis
en avant pendant marine le pen pendant
très longtemps
quelle mesure en qualité de député vous
pourriez porter même si vous n'avez pas
changé à la face du commerce de
proximité en france mais vous pouvez
soutient des projets vous avez peut-être
des idées
alors il ya des mesures locales qui ne
dépendent pas du député je prends un
exemple puisque aujourd'hui la majorité
département et 100% républicain
l'augmentation de près de 70% des impôts
locaux
eh ben ça c'est d'une catastrophe pour
bien sûr les habitants résidants mais
également pour les commerces parce que
les leurs taxes locales ont augmenté
d'autant donc limité déjà là les impôts
ensuite il est vrai que on a des charges
sociales extrêmement élevé et un petit
commerce a besoin comme de salariés ils
ensemble à dire pas mal de salariés les
petits commerces
mais souvent les commerçants les petits
patrons n'arrivent plus à payer leurs
salariés compte tenu des charges
importantes que ceux ci qu'ils doivent
payer pour ceux ci donc sous les déjà
mesures très simples baisse des impôts
baisse des charges sociales
ça permettra de donner une certaine
autonomie financière aux petites
entreprises aux commerçants et puis
ensuite on parle de transport en commun
c'est très bien mais aujourd'hui
beaucoup de personnes se déplacent en
voiture et essayer de rentrer en voiture
dans certaines villes dans la sa
contrition
c'est extrêmement compliqué extrêmement
compliqué donc des aires de
stationnement on arrête de prendre des
automobilistes pour des vaches à lait et
de l'oeil les taxes est systématiquement
gens mettent des pv pour défaut de
stationnement qu'on respecte
l'automobiliste qui vient surtout de
quoi y ait des personnes âgées qui
peuvent pas marcher longtemps on
récupère mais aux gens de dire aux motos
proches des centres villes fabien était
pour beaucoup la france sur le commerce
de
possibilité aux propositions vos idées
que vous pourriez porter au palais
bourbon
alors vu que les députés seront des élus
de la nation mais ce serait plutôt une
politique nationale que je mettrai en
place mais qui aurait des répercussions
soit là sur les dynamiques locales
en fait ça serait la lutte contre le
dumping qui prend plusieurs formes
ça peut être le dumping social avec des
salaires de misère le jumping
environnementale avec le non respect des
normes environnementales ou les nobles
ou le dumping monétaire l'oeil qui est
le fait de sous-évaluer une monnaie pour
s'accaparer des marchés pour lutter
justement ce contre le dumping
nous mettrons en place un
protectionnisme protectionnisme qui
permettrait de réduire la différence
qu'il ya entre les produits français
fabriquent en france respectant les
normes sociales et mentales et
salariales française est pénalisé
justement les normes des producteurs
étrangers qui ne respectent pas ces
normes là l'intérêt serait en fait de
réduire la différence du coût qui peut y
avoir entre les deux est un site et
inciter les autres pays à respecter les
normes françaises qui sont plutôt dans
l'ensemble bonne même si elle reste à
enfin certaines restent à améliorer
mais ils sont quand même bonne dans leur
ensemble du coup cette politique là
aurait une répercussion sur le dynamisme
local avec une rennaise
réindustrialisation de la france plus
d'emplois et ses plus de création de
richesse on va voir ce que vous
souhaitiez réagir ce week-end et antoine
barreau parce que vous aviez un peu
d'avancé
à vous de gérer votre temps de parole
antoine barreau sur le commerce de
proximité
donc je rejoins je cultive debout la
france c'est à dire que il faut voir ça
plutôt à l'échelle macroéconomique et
rééquilibrer un peu les choses quand on
d'abord commencerait par une remise en
cause de toutes les possibilités de le
payer ses impôts de diminuer ses impôts
et 2 ainsi que le vient de le faire la
société auchan qui a économisé des
millions alors que les petits
commerçants eux ils payent leurs impôts
comme tout le monde
alors déjà éviter de ramener une égalité
au niveau de la trêve fiscale traitement
fiscal
sophie calle représentants de david
douillet enfin suppléant de david
douillet en finir avec l'excès de charge
avec cette norme les refondre le rsi
entre ambiante en parfait on va voir
s'afficher dans quelques instants une
nouvelle fois du couvent au temps de
parole on va voir que ça s'est
rééquilibré un petit peu voilà toujours
un peu d'avancé pour antoine barreau
vous n'avez pas évidemment 412 minutes
mais 4 minutes 12
et puis un peu de retard pour marie
noëlle bas haut poursuit ce débat pour
la 12e circonscription des yvelines avec
la moralisation de la vie politique ou
plutôt désormais le projet pour la
confiance dans notre vie démocratique
c'est le nouveau nom officiel projet
présenté il ya quelques jours par la
garde par le garde des sceaux françois
bayrou
ce projet prévoit l'interdiction
notamment pour les ministres d'exercer
des fonctions à la tête d'exécutifs
locaux ou encore la création d'une
banque de la démocratie qui pourra
prêter de l'argent aux partis pour leur
campagne électorale il ya beaucoup de
mesures
vous serez amené à vous prononcer dès
cet été sur deux projets de loi si vous
êtes élu alors voterez vous pour et
contre
et pourquoi marie noëlle bas puisque
vous avez un petit peu de retard je vous
propose de
vous prononcer en première là dessus et
la moralisation de la vie politique
c'était un de mes premiers axes de
communication avant que monsieur
macroule de soi ne soit élu donc oui je
suis tout à fait pour je trouve ça
franchement dommage qu'ils aient changé
de nom parce que moralisation ça voulait
dire quelque chose que tout le monde
comprenait la l'histoire de la confiance
c'est un peu plus abscons mais
oui bien sûr moi je trouve que c'est
très important la transparence c'est
très important savoir effectivement là
on vient d'apprendre qu'il ya dix il ya
dix assistants parlementaires européens
du modem qui était plus ou moins en
emploi fictif
donc oui bien sûr c'est extrêmement
important que aujourd'hui les françaises
et les français reprennent confiance
dans leur dans leurs élus le problème
que je vois moi là aujourd'hui c'est que
au fond on remplace une élite
technocratique qui vient de l'ena par
une autre élite technocratique qui vient
d'achever les qui finalement a à peu
près les mêmes objectifs
finalement travailler plus pour pour
elle et pour cette élite que pour les
françaises et les français dans leur
ensemble
jean luc hallé pour le front national
écoutez c'est très simple quand il s'en
suit l'exemple même j'ai décidé de faire
de la politique au moment où j'ai pris
ma retraite
c'est à dire que je considère que la
politique n'a pas à mes pieds ne pas
être une source de revenus
donc je défend l'intégrité l'honnêteté
j'en suis je dirais le symbole je fais
de la vie associative depuis j'ai
commencé à l'âge de 16 ans en tant que
secouriste à la croix rouge
j'ai poursuivi par les clubs sportifs je
continue j'ai toujours donné mon temps
au service des autres et ça
malheureusement nous sommes des hommes
politiques regardent d'abord ce qui peut
leur rapporter le plus d'argent
avant de regarder l'intérêt des citoyens
et c'est fort dommage donc bravo qu'on
m'aura l'idée que maryse beaucoup plus
lourdement et qu'on se passe sans pitié
pour les gens vont savoir que
l'américain devient leur vie tout de
même je ne connais plus le le
précisément le montant un peu plus de
5000 euros donc continuer je vous ai
compris a martelé celle ci pour
m'indiquer mais voilà qu'on soit très
clair et qu'on moi je suis pour la
suppression du mandat électif à vie pour
des gens condamné pour détournement de
fonds
voilà sofitel pour les républicains
mais alors
david douillet est très favorable à la
loi de moralisation de la vie publique
oui faut le retour de la confiance en
politique où il faut assurer la probité
des émules la république oui il faut du
renouvellement mais pas n'importe
comment et pas avec n'importe qui
aujourd'hui le problème de l'assemblée
nationale s'il ya une surreprésentation
d'un certain nombre de catégories
socioprofessionnelles premier rang
desquels les fonctionnaires et les
professions libérales
pourquoi parce que l'artisan le
commerçant le patron de tpe pme
l'agriculteur lui peut pas se permettre
du jour lendemain de mettre la clé sous
la porte licencier ses salariés
si j'ai cinq ans à l'assemblée nationale
sans garantie de retrouver une activité
professionnelle après donc pour ces
professions là il n'y a pas de statut
qui leur garantit l'emploi à vie donc
oui au renouvellement mais il faut
encore se donner les moyens de ce
renouvellement et pour ça il faut un
véritable statut
on n'est toujours pas aujourd'hui fabien
mettez pour debout la france votre point
de vue et puis peut-être réagir à ce
statut qui vient d'être d'être évoquées
font non je peux réagir ce que je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de boulot à faire chez
les républicains en termes de mauvaises
politiques d un gros chantier
en fait nous ce serait 3 points
justement ben je vais enchaîner ce
serait de rendre de demander aux
candidats d'avoir un casier judiciaire
vierge
ce qui paraît un ce qui paraît logique
au premier abord faut savoir que dont
près de 500 métiers on demande à un
casier judiciaire vierge et on ne
demande pas aux élus qui vont voter les
lois
c'est quand même paradoxal que des
personnes qui violent les lois se puisse
les potées
par la suite d'ailleurs je profite de ce
moment là je sais que d'autres ont fait
sur le plateau pour montrer mon casier
judiciaire qui est vierge
deuxième point je souhaite enfin on
souhaite revenir sur le régime spécial
des députés
parce qu'en fait il faut savoir que 1
lorsqu'un salarié cotise un euro il
reçoit un euro cinquante pour sa
retraite
2 euros pour un fonctionnaire et je sais
pas si vous savez mais un élu reçoit 6
euros pour un euro cotisé
ce qui paraît enfin ce qui me paraît
énorme sur la fin c'était un régime
spécial qui est immoral
d'ailleurs il ya font pâles qui fait là
beaucoup de documents voilà et en fait
on se fait en fait revenir dessus et
tout simplement l'annuler pour l'indexer
sur le privé parce qu'il n'y a pas de
raison que les élus et d'un régime
spécial et demande aux français de faire
des efforts et enfin dernière dernier
point pour le coup je tiens on va
soutenir une mesure de benoît mois
emmanuel macron alors et emmanuel macron
savoisy savait très court en fait nous
avons nicolas dupont aignan a proposé de
revenir sur la réserve parlementaire qui
est un puyoô clientéliste et il voulait
en faire un fonds d'actions de support
pour le territoire et les projets et
justement on est content de voir que les
modèles macron à
emmanuel macron a repris cette mesure là
et nous allons si elle est appliquée
dans les termes qu'on souhaite nous
allons la beauté avant de donner la
parole à monsieur barreaux marie noëlle
bas mot soutirer registre sur le statut
de l'élu parce que je pense que c'est
extrêmement important c'est vrai qu'il
faut avoir un statut de l'élu
bien bien fondé et puis parler d'
exemplarité aussi puisque finalement on
parle de moralisation et on parle peu
d'exemplarité et c'est vrai que quand on
voit comment se comporte un certain
nombre d'élus et que d'autres d'aider
les gamins des cités sont en coopération
immédiate par exemple c'est vrai que
c'est un vrai problème
antoine barreau ou conclus et ce tour de
table sur la moralisation de la vie
politique
votre et vous y êtes bien entendu je le
voterai parce que qu'ils ne voteraient
pas les mesures qui viennent les
retraités indiqué par le ver ou
simplement je note aussi que j'ai tout à
l'heure que il n'est pas prévu justement
de
de prévoir un casier judiciaire vierge
alors je trouve ça quand même assez
extraordinaire que ce qu'on le demande à
des fonctionnaires puisque les
fonctionnaires doivent avoir un casier
judiciaire vierge
que ce soit à secrétaire de mairie où
que ce soit même un simple gardien de
square alors que les députés on ne leur
demande pas alors il faudrait ce que
nous voulons aussi c'est supprimer les
conflits d'intérêts ça non plus ça n'est
pas traitée alors il faut râle oui il
faudra traiter ça dans le temps qu'il
faudra faire des amendements
donc si j'étais élu je ferai voter ces
amendements je vais proposer en tout cas
et nous verrons bien quand même au sujet
de cette moralisation ce que va faire le
président de la république puisque
monsieur michel roussin qui vient d'être
promue par un décret de monsieur
hollande commandeur de la légion
d'honneur a été lui condamné pour à 4 en
deux
prison avec sursis 80000 euros d'amendé
alors que lorsqu'on reçoit la légion
d'honneur on doit avoir un casier
judiciaire vierge
alors que va faire monsieur mâcon qui
doit qu'à la possibilité d'annuler le
décret de monsieur alors sa
représentante n'est pas là ce soir donc
on ne pourra pas répondre à sa place on
va voir sa fiche des temps de parole
pour voir que de nouveaux écarts se sont
creusés donc ceux qui ont un peu moins
de temps de parole pourront peut être
rajouter quelque chose si le s'ils le
souhaitent voilà sofica haine c'est vous
qui avaient le plus de retard peut être
ce que vous voulez rajouter quelque
chose sur la moralisation de la
politique de la vie politique ne
rencontrait pour la carte blanche
vous en profiterez pour la carte blanche
ça tombe bien on y passe à cette carte
blanche elle vous permet à chacun de
mettre en avant le point que vous
souhaitez monsieur barreau monsieur
mettez vous aurez beaucoup moins de
temps que les autres candidats pour
exposer votre point de vue on prend
l'ordre inverse du début de l'émission
on commence avec vous fabien mais tu es
candidat de debout la france vous avez
la parole mais très rapidement de nac
en fait on va faire la guerre à la
délinquance et à la criminalité faut
savoir qu'en france il ya 4 million de
crimes et de délits qui ont été recensés
en 2015 dont 500000 agression c'est
énorme
alors si la sécurité est un droit le
l'élu a le devoir de l'assuré c'est pour
ça que nous allons est d'ailleurs un
plaisir on a eu une triste affaire pour
récemment avec le mali clôture du burger
king qui a abattu un homme à plusieurs
nous stresse on récupère d'autorité
voilà restaurer l'autorité de l'état
protéger la société de ce genre de
bombes humaines et mettre fin au laxisme
judiciaire
pour cela nous allons renforcer les
forces de l'ordre avec un recrutement
durcir la législation matériaux
terrorisme et de délinquance et
construire davantage de places de prison
fossard qu'on en angleterre on à 96
mille places soit 48 de plus qu'en
france
donc on va se réaligner sur l'angleterre
jean le gall et vous avez un peu plus de
temps pour votre carte blanche
on vous écoute qu'elle n'en voulait
mettre en avant à peu près le même est
différemment la sécurité mais de façon
globale la sécurité commente un sécurité
du pays bien évidemment et notamment
nous faisons des missions extérieures à
la france avec notre armée armée qui n'a
strictement aucun moyen des avions dont
certains datent depuis 30 ans des chars
depuis 40 ans qui tombe constamment
panne dont dix ans notre premier point
en dehors question de voix de nos
effectifs de police et décidé de
remettre un peu en dehors de l'ordre par
des moyens dans la justice
c'est déjà de s'occuper de l'armée et
immédiatement on ferait qu' et 2 % du
budget national consacré à l'armée et
pourtant dans les années à venir vers
trois courses en trois pour cent du
budget national que ce complément soit
financée par la france ou de préférence
par l'europe puisque on intervient
souvent au nom de l'europe
antoine barreau vous avez une courte
carte blanche comme fabien mettay
allez-y il faudra mettre l'accent sur la
solidarité parce que actuellement tous
les gouvernements en place y compris le
gouvernement de monsieur hollande
rechercher la rentabilité la rentabilité
partout alors qu'avant elle se faisait
simplement le privé dans les entreprises
maintenant la rentabilité elle est dans
les services publics dans les hôpitaux
c'est absolument scandaleux donc il faut
être développer la solidarité par le
partage du travail par le partage de la
richesse
il faut savoir que actuellement 10% de
la population française détient 50% du
patrimoine français simplement 10 % des
gens de riches détiennent 50 jours et
les cinq arap sang qui restent désolé
bas ne possède que 8% alors il va
falloir aussi être un peu solidaires sur
la richesse et grâce à la fiscalité sont
évidemment désolés de vous couper j
invite les téléspectateurs à regarder
vos sites internet soient personnels
soin de vos partis pour aller plus loin
on va dire que ces débats seront sort
des mises en bouche pour ceux qui
souhaitent s'intéresser et voter
dimanche prochain sauf week-end je
rappelle aussi que vous êtes la
candidate suppléant de david douillet
pour lr et lui dit votre carte blanche
vous avez un peu plus de temps vous
alors pour y ait des problèmes éthiques
on n'a pas pu évoquer ce soir les
transports le numérique avec des 8
juillet on s'est concerté on a voulu
vous parlez de santé ce soir on visitait
cet après midi le centre hospitalier
intercommunal
voici au saint germain en laye on a
piqué sa vie d'urgence la maternité la
néonat on a évidemment rencontré un
personnel médical absolument formidable
et dévoués qui travaillent dans des
conditions difficiles alors la lutte
contre le chômage c'est évidemment la
priorité de son quinquennat la santé
doit l'être également
moi je voulais avoir un mot pour les
aidants familiaux
ils sont 8 millions cinq cent mille en
france pendant la rencontre et beaucoup
à l'occasion des permanences que fait
david douillet toutes les semaines dans
sa circonscription pourquoi parce qu'ils
sont souvent malheureusement totalement
démuni face au système de santé face aux
frais engendrés par le handicap par les
maladies de longue durée par la perte
d'autonomie de nos aînés moi je voulais
vous citer un exemple de ce que david
douillet a fait concrètement 2012 il a
déposé une proposition de loi qui visait
à permettre un emprunt à taux zéro pour
toutes les personnes qui devaient faire
des travaux de réhabilitation de leur
domicile pour accueillir des personnes
en situation de handicap cette
proposition de loi elle a été retoqué
par le gouvernement socialiste
mais moi ce que je souhaite parce que
david douillet va taper en vente ou un
député de bon sens un député efficace
pour la réussite de ce pays c'est que si
les s'il est élu
réélu le 18 juin il puisse se redéposer
cette proposition mois et que la manne
nouvelle majorité par le monde
r vote ces lois de bon sens et qui
viendra j'en doute pas aidé concrètement
des milliers de familles qui vivent des
situations difficiles
enfin marie noëlle bas pour le parti
socialiste vous concluez cette première
partie d'émission votre carte blanche
moi je ferai un appel à la réflexion des
citoyennes et les citoyens
il faut aller voter parce que lundi sera
trop tard pour regretter le
la direction que le gouvernement prend
qui est une direction ultralibérale avec
réduction du droit de manifester avec
suppression de l'sf avec la
déconstruction des droits sociaux et je
dirais que la solidarité étant une
priorité extrêmement importante il faut
savoir dans quelle société on a envie de
vivre et dans quelle société on a envie
que nos enfants grandissent
c'est la fin de cette première partie
d'émission non on avait un ordre pour
conclure une nouvelle fois on peut aller
sur internet aussi pour éventuellement
trouver vos professions de foi où tout
le monde va les recevoir par courrier
merci à vous 5 d'être venu en plateau
tout de suite de nouveaux candidats vont
arriver en plateau je vous propose avant
tout de regarder ce débat qui présente
ce sujet qui présente les enjeux de
cette 12e circonscription avec ce sujet
de camille lambert +200 3000 habitants
et un députés pour les représenter la
12e circonscription des yvelines
s'étendent de poissy à plaisir avec le
canton de montfort l'amaury elle devra
choisir si elle souhaite à nouveau faire
confiance au député sortant david
douillet élu en 2009 en législative
partielle puis en 2012 avec près de 55 %
des voix
le républicain remet son siège en jeu la
circonscription traditionnellement à
droite le donnent favori
l'ancien judoka a obtenu le soutien
d'une partie des élus locaux mais treize
candidats rêvent de lui voler la vedette
parmi eux la marcheuse florence granger
elle est investie par le parti du
président de la république
emmanuel macron son manque d'expérience
en politique pourrait jouer en sa
défaveur
mais elle souhaite incarner le renouveau
le parti socialiste arrivé au second
tour en 2012 avait obtenu 45 % des voix
cette fois il espère rafler la mise
avec sa candidate marie noëlle bas le
front national troisième au premier tour
de 2012 avec près de 10% se fixe
l'objectif de la première place jean-luc
galère représente le parti d'extrême
droite
il était déjà candidat aux élections
départementales de 2015 il avait obtenu
11 85% des voix au deuxième tour
pour faire entendre la voix des
travailleurs au sein de lutte ouvrière
jean pierre mercier délégué syndical du
groupe psa peugeot citroën il était
porte-parole de nathalie arthaud durant
la présidentielle dans une
circonscription à cheval entre ville et
campagne
europe ecologie les verts a investi
patricia charton engagés dans des
associations écologiques locales
elle souhaite préserver la ruralité le
parti était arrivé quatrième au premier
tour en 2012
parmi les autres candidats écologistes
isabelle fournière et florent grassi
antoine barreau candidats france
insoumise devra faire face à la
communiste françoise pinson à droite on
retrouve mario mouillon fabien mettay
pour debout la france et daniel weber
soutenu par jean marie le pen
enfin stéphane roussillo est investi par
l'upm le parti de françois asselineau
deuxième partie de cette émission vous
voyez c'est du direct on s'installe de
ces débats pour la 12e circonscription
des yvelines avec quatre nouveaux
candidats qui nous ont rejoints en
plateau daniel weber candidate d'extrême
droite investi par le parti de la france
stéphane roussillon candidats et divers
investi par l'union populaire
républicaine jean pierre mercier
candidat d'extrême gauche investi par
lutte ouvrière et patricia charton
candidat écologiste investi par europe
ecologie les verts bonsoir vous 4
évidemment je précise que je donne les
nuances politiques de la préfecture je
vais te donner aussi les partis qui vous
avez investi pour que tout soit clair
pour vous informer aussi nous avons
tenté de contacter les 14 candidats pour
participer à ce débat pour la 12ème
circonscription
certains étaient injoignables d'autres
n'ont jamais répondu
certains aussi n'ont pas pu se déplacer
c'est le cas notamment de florence
grange où la candidate de la république
en marche
cette parenthèse fermée je vous rappelle
que vos temps de parole sont
chronométrées vous pouvez donc vous
interpellez penser quand même à gérer
votre temps de parole et première
question qu'on pose à tous les candidats
pourquoi les électeurs doivent nous
faire confiance dimanche daniel weber
vous êtes la première à prendre la
parole
r déjà je voudrais vous dire que vos
parties de la france nous ne sommes pas
d extrême droite
je comprends très bien que les
personnels
de police qui ne sont pas des
politiciens essaient de ranger des gens
dans des cases
mais nous ne sommes pas de droite
nous sommes de la droite nationale c'est
une grosse différence contrairement à
d'autres partis qui pourrait être un peu
plus dur que nous nous défend
essentiellement le le peuple au niveau
des du travail des décharges au niveau
déjà dans les entreprises je disais au
niveau de la liberté où vous voudrez
quand même limiter l'immigration parce
qu'on en est arrivé à 12 millions de
gens qui seront rentrés dans votre pays
un peu je dirais trop facilement et vous
voudrez une immigration choisie c'est
pas pour ça qu'on d'extrême droite une
fois je me réfère à la préfecture oui ce
n'est pas notre choix allons je vous
apporte comme une preuve que nous nous
sommes répertoriés dans l'union des
patriotes et pas dans les stades droite
alors en tant que journaliste compétent
vous devriez nous en tenir à des
informations sérieuses et pas répéter
bêtement cette année l'information j'y
penserai pour dans 5 ans en 2022 pour me
stéphane au roussillon pour le père
pourquoi les électeurs doivent t'ils
vous faire confiance dimanche prochain
alors bonjour déjà effectivement
je représente lui p r et lupe air qui
est sorti je dire à la face des français
à l'élection lors de l'élection
présidentielle est un mouvement qui a
pour but de rassembler l'ensemble des
français au dessus des clivages droite
gauche et qui prône un quelque chose de
simple c'est que nous ne sommes plus en
démocratie depuis le mois de mai 2005 et
le vote du référendum où les français
ont choisi de sortir de l'union
européenne ça fait 12 ans que nous nous
restons de force dans une union
européenne
les analyses invariable de françois
salido depuis dix ans je sais de
stupéfiants mais jour après jour et a
vocation à détruire notre pays et les
avancées sociales que nous avons d'aidé
défendu depuis 200 ans et aux plus de 8
200 en c pour ceux ci que nous nous
battons et nous espérons pendant les
cinq ans à venir avoir le droit à un peu
plus à la parole que pendant les 10
dernières années écoulées
jean pierre mercier pour le team brière
le tout vrilliard excusez moi même
question pourquoi les électeurs de
petites vous faire confiance des manches
mais écoutez moi je suis un militant
ouvrier je travaille je suis ouvrier je
travaille à l usine de psa à poissy
je me présente pour défendre comme comme
l'a défendu nathalie arthaud dans la
campagne des présidentielles le fait que
le camp des travailleurs doit se faire
entendre dans ces élections législatives
tous ceux qui n'ont que leur salaire qui
n'ont que leur allocation qui n'ont que
leur pension pour vivre ont des intérêts
bien spécifique à défendre dans cette
société et on le voit avec ce nouveau
gouvernement qui à peine mis en place à
être vraiment a déclaré la guerre au
monde du travail et donc il faut se
saisir de ces élections législatives
pour faire entendre sa voix en tant que
travailleurs pour faire entendre ses
intérêts politiques face à face au
patronat à tous les capitalistes qui
veulent absolument non pas libérer le
travail mais libéré l'exploitation est
véritablement nous faire la peau
patricia charton pour europe ecologie
les verts vous concluez ce premier tour
de table pourquoi les électeurs doivent
t'ils vous faire confiance dimanche eh
bien je pense ce pouvoir représenter la
ce que ce que j'aimerais pour le futur
de nos enfants
on parle beaucoup de politique on parle
beaucoup de positionnement par rapport à
des sujets qui qui sont des rengaines
depuis des dizaines d'années mais on
parle très peu de climat on parle très
peu de biodiversité on parle très peu de
la survie de l'être humain sur cette
planète
alors évidemment la france n'est pas la
seule à pouvoir régler ce problème mais
il faut absolument qu'on soit une
lanterne pour le reste du monde dans ce
non ce
dans cet esprit là et qu'on soit
qu'on soit voilà une une vigie aussi
pour faire en sorte de mettre en place
les systèmes qui nous permettrait de
changer de modèle et de d'aller vers
quelque chose qui qui soit vivable et
désirable pour chacun merci pour vos
réponses je rappelle que vous pouvez
échanger entre vous et évidemment ça
sera à compter sur le temps de parole de
côté des bars cafés
voilà je suis très déçu que la
république en marche ne soit pas
présenté nous sommes également parce que
j'avais pris soin de téléphoner à mes
concurrents pour mon collègue m
pour sûr que tout le monde était présent
la république en marge devrait présente
et je trouve que un parti politique qui
représente mais chut macron et qui a
l'indécence de ne pas être présente ce
soir me chokri ben le mans c'est notre
ca ce midi on poursuit avec notre m
notre thème principal pour ce débat le
développement économique en rapport
aussi avec l'actualité puisque le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron souhaite
accélérer souhaite aller vite pour
réformer le code du travail
objectif de l'exécutif amplifié et
soutenir la baisse entrevue du chômage
selon lui évidemment si vous êtes dans
dix jours élu député
quel sera votre priorité vous pour
soutenir le développement économique
jean pierre mercier vous êtes à
contre-pied on va dire de beaucoup
d'électeurs de politique plutôt sur
cette question là
vous dites vous il faut interdire les
licenciements augmenter le salaire
minimum à 1800 euros ou encore accentuer
le contrôle des travailleurs sur les
entreprises est ce que vous pouvez par
exemple nous développer ce dernier point
et me dire en quoi ils pourraient
permettre de faire baisser le chômage
vous savez les entreprises
en tout cas les les patrons les chefs
d'entreprise les actionnaires ont pour
habitude et comme comme mode de vie de
travail et dans toute opacité
c'est à dire que les comptes des
entreprises qui sont présentés aux
organisations syndicales ne sont pas
forcément les vrais je prendrais
simplement comme exemple cette
entreprise gms qui est sous traitant de
psa et c'est psa le donneur d'ordre qui
est en train de les étrangler tout ça
pour gagner encore plus de profits si
l'ensemble des salariés si l'ensemble
des travailleurs pouvaient mettre leur
nez dans les comptes des grandes
entreprises pour savoir exactement quels
sont les contrats commerciaux qui ont
été passées pour savoir exactement
l'état de la trésorerie
les bénéfices qu'est ce qu'ils en font
tous ses bénéfices
on pourrait aisément démontrer que quand
une entreprise se déclare en déficit ou
se déclare en difficulté pour justifier
des plans de licenciement ce n'est
absolument pas vrai ce sont des
mensonges et psa on est l'exemple le
plus inquiète d'ailleurs apprécié donc
sur la deuxième sera pensions tout à
fait c'est psa est une grosse entreprise
qui pèse énormément dans la
circonscription de poissy dans la dans
la 12e circonscription
c'est évident que psa n'a jamais été en
réelle difficulté
ça n'a été que pour justifier la
fermeture de l'usiné de psa aulnay et il
faut absolument imposer à l'ensemble des
grandes entreprises à commencer par
celles qui font des bénéfices
une interdiction pure et simple de
licencier pour répartir le travail entre
tous les faire rentrer les chômeurs dans
les entreprises pour pouvoir travailler
tous et - patricia charton si l'on se
réfère au programme de votre parti pour
ces élections selon vous la création
d'emplois et donc le développement
économique passe par la transition
écologique qu'elle est du coup la
priorité puisque c'est un vaste sujet la
transition écologique qu'elle un projet
vous pourriez rapidement porté si vous
êtes élu député
la transition écologique on en a on a
plusieurs volets évidemment on à
l'agriculture en premier lieu je me bats
vous n'avez pas mon tract là j'aurais pu
vous le laissez c'est dommage je me bats
et socialement pour pour la transition
agricole locale les pièges than hell
locales et paysannes évidemment
évidemment et avec des techniques qui
sont éprouvés aujourd'hui d'agroécologie
d'agro iphone d'agroforesterie de traves
de non travail du sol qui sont donc qui
sont donc appuyé par la recherche
agronomique française par l'école
agroparistech par exemple dont je
connais un petit peu le le dessin
puisque voilà et comme je suis à côté de
grignon j'habite ben donc je connais
assez bien aussi le problème du site de
grillons lalande divergent
la transition écologique c'est aussi
l'énergie l'énergie nous a permis de
nous développer depuis 200 ans dé
développer énormément de de production
et ses productions
elle est à l'origine évidemment du
réchauffement climatique de la perte de
biodiversité
donc on en revient toujours à la même
chose on revient à quelque chose qui qui
et massifier industrialisés et je pense
que le travail si on veut parler travail
n'ont pas d'emploi parce que c'est pas
la même chose
le travail devrait être rémunéré une
maman qui travaille rend service à la
nation
elle est la porte évidemment à ce que
d'autres pourraient apporter dans un
centre de formation daniel weber votre
parti je cite si on se réfère à votre
profession de foi veut en finir avec le
socialisme économique l écrasement
fiscales et sociales et les gaspillages
publics
quand vous parler par exemple de
socialisme économique vous pensez à quoi
concrètement les socialistes prix que
vous dites c'est à dire une deux une un
développement des allocations dans tous
les sens qui deviennent comment un appel
d'air à l'immigration qui n'est pas
choisi je veux dire que on se trouve
maintenant dans une situation encore
comme je le disais tout à l'heure on est
à 12 millions de dhs émigré en france si
ces 12 millions étaient des gens qui
savent rouler s'intégrer et dont le
leitmotiv est justement d'intégrer une
société et la république française il y
aurait pas de problème malheureusement
je suis obligé de voir constate un tout
le monde que dans les émigrés il ya des
gens qui viennent pour ne pas s'intégrer
le plus d'immigrés plus de développement
et pas de vie plus d'immigrés chez
d'immigration choisie
j'ai par exemple concernant les faits
les 15000 fichier s il est nécessaire
que les raccompagner à la frontière
je ne trouve pas d'autre solution on va
pas en plus les héberger dans nos
prisons on va pas construire des prisons
pour ces gens là s'ils veulent pas
s'intégrer
tant pis pour eux s'ils veulent
s'intégrer ils sont les bienvenus
et je redis encore c'est une petite
minorité qui déshonore et leur pays et
nos religions alors c'est aux membres de
je dirais des communautés en question de
faire le trailer très le tri dans leurs
partisans à stéphane roussillon pour le
p r lui aussi au excusez-moi roussillon
excusez-moi l'upper développe de
nombreux pots aussi autour de l'économie
et notamment
c'est l'un des points une baisse des
cotisations patronales pour les artisans
les commerçants les tpe pme
c'est l'une des priorités pour vous ce
point là alors je pense qu'effectivement
en termes de développement économique il
faut totalement inversé les choses
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs je ne peut pas
dissocier le terme développement
économique du développement social s'est
fait dans cette thématique ça prouve
bien l'air du temps nous avons un mot
nous tu nous travaillons aujourd'hui
dans un modèle économique qui est
purement économique où l'économique 2000
le politique et le social et nous
mettons les êtres humains au service de
l'économie alors que pour moi l'économie
est au service des êtres humains
je pense que l'inversion est essentiel
est que ce modèle là est imposée par
l'union européenne je regrette de le
répéter mais nous allons élire une
assemblée nationale aujourd'hui qui n'a
que le pouvoir de retranscrire les
propositions de loi de la commission
européenne c'est le seul pouvoir
corrompt nos députés pendant les 5
premières prochaines années donc je vais
vous donner quelques chiffres en termes
de développement économique aujourd'hui
qui vous montre un petit peu l'amplitude
des de ce retournement qu'il faut
effectuer aujourd'hui vous avez 70
milliards d'évasion fiscale qui est
notamment créés par les grandes
entreprises qui s'arrange au regard des
lois qui leur permet aujourd'hui d'aller
faire leurs profits dans les pays
étrangers où ne paye pas d'imposition
vous avez aujourd'hui 800 pauvres puis
100 personnes par jour qui passe en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
parallèlement nous avons un impôt sur le
revenu des français particuliers qui
représentent environ 50 milliards qui
est exactement le montant que nous
payons pour le service de la dette par
an donc vous avez là ici environ 140
milliards
je vous prie d'imaginer les moyens de
feu aux orions si nous pouvions rien
affecté c'est ces moyens-là et changer
les lois qui permettent de détourner ces
fonds là qui sont les fonds
pour le peuple dans quelques instants on
va voir vos temps de parole s'afficher
après cette première thématique on va
peut-être l'approfondir un petit peu
avec on va voir lors les temps de parole
s'afficher tout de suite voilà ici vous
voyez jean pierre merci un peu de retard
stéphane roux si haut si vous avez un
peu d'avancé daniel weber sur sur les
autres une minute d'avancé
je voudrais vous faire réagir par
exemple jean pierre mercier sur l'une
des positions de lutte ouvrière
concernant le protectionnisme vous allez
à l'encontre là aussi un peu du débat
actuel et il se fait puisque vous vous
dites que c'est un piège le
protectionnisme expliquez nous pourquoi
bien sûr que c'est un piège c'est un
piège qui est organisé par par le
patronat par les actionnaires des deux
de ces grandes entreprises c'est faire
croire que en fermant les frontières en
se repliant sur le pays
on va pouvoir s'en sortir lors dans le
fond on mélange à la fois
les milliardaires les riches les
capitalistes et puis on est on est on
les assemble on les rassemble avec tout
le reste de la population c'est-à-dire
les 95% du reste c'est à dire l'ensemble
des travailleurs et c'est évident que
c'est que c'est un leurre que c'est un
piège
les vrais ennemis ceux ceux qui
licencient ceux qui sont responsables du
chômage ceux qui sont responsables de la
misère aujourd'hui ce qui bloque les
salaires ce qui envoie la société dans
le mur ce qui qui font de l'argent avec
de l'argent c'est bien c'est bien les
capitalistes c'est bien les responsables
de ces grandes entreprises ils ont pas
du tout besoin de l'europe pour faire la
loi travail ils ont pas du tout besoin
de l'europe pour licencier à tour de
bras pour supprimer des emplois chez psa
et dans toutes les grandes entreprises
ils le font eux-mêmes parce qu'ils y ont
intérêt c'est évident que tout le
discours du protectionnisme est fait
pour diviser les travailleurs entre les
différents pays vous savez psa viennent
de racheter opel c'est des dizaines
du sinn à travers l'europe c'est
quarante mille salariés les salariés qui
travaillent en allemagne les salariés
qui travaillent en france ont des
intérêts communs par delà les frontières
contre la famille peugeot qui est bien
décidé comme le gouvernement à faire la
peau des travailleurs stéphane rossini
vous souhaitiez réagir puisque oui on a
notamment parlé d'europe à l'instant je
sortir de l'europe et l'associer au
protectionnisme et est une étude est un
raccourci qui facilite malheureusement
pas le débat le sortir de l'europe est
juste remettre un contrôle aujourd'hui
redéfinir ce qui est un peuple un peuple
qui ait décidé de solidaires qui décide
de mettre en commun des biens communs de
participer à un impôt est de savoir
auquel bénéfique à quels bénéfices il
veut il veut niveau de mettre au service
et impôts madame nous parlait tout à
l'heure d'un grand plan de transition
écologique
je rappelle que lors des trente
glorieuses la france était libre
économiquement et avait décidé
d'investir massivement sur le nucléaire
pour son indépendance
aujourd'hui il est factuel qu'elle doit
se poser la question pour réévaluer
cette cet investissement et et dépasser
des fonds sur défendre d'écologie
nouvelle elle n'a aucun moyen de le
faire aujourd'hui dans un système où
elle est totalement dépendant d'une
politique internationale
dépendante des américains où le seul but
est d'aller consommer pendant les 50
prochaines années les réserves
pétrolières qui existe parce que ce sont
des milliards et des milliards d'argent
en jeu tant que cet argent là certains
ne seront pas appropriée les nouvelles
technologies ne malheureusement ne
sortiront pas à grande échelle pour
sauver la planète
patricia charton est-ce que vous
souhaitiez éventuellement région et puis
votre point de vue sur des mesures
protectionnistes qui pourrait soutenir
le développement économique c'est la
position de beaucoup de partis est ce
que c'est c'est l'avocat général quand
on fait un garrot
ça circule beaucoup moins donc le sait
quelque chose tout à fait naturel et en
économie c'est la même chose quand on
on veut fermer les frontières on
s'enferme et et en vend pas plus qu'on
achète donc maintenant vous êtes vous
même par exemple quand on prend le
canton prend votre profession de foi
favorable à une relocalisation de
l'économie vous pensez à quoi
eh bien je pense aussi bien évidemment
dans le monde agricole et toutes les
possibilités transformation
agroalimentaire relocalisé à des
échelles beaucoup moins inhumaine
aujourd'hui faire en sorte aussi de
décroître
parce que la croissance ça n'est lié
qu'à la la consommation d'énergie donc
la consommation dernière d'énergie faut
le rappeler aujourd'hui ce sont des
énergies fossiles même l'uranium qu'il
faut aller il faut les détruire la loose
on y est et voilà et
et cet uranium on va le chercher dans
les pays du sud et donc on déséquilibre
encore plus l'économie locale et on
retrouve encore plus de gens qui ont
besoin de se sauver de chez eux parce
que il n'y a plus rien à manger donc
donc tout tout est lié tout est lié et
ferme et fermé les frontières ne va pas
leur accord ne soit pas le rapport oui
oui je regarde regarde et le chili en
lisant son casque à 100% de d'énergie
éolienne et solaire
et ça marche très bien les l'électricité
devenue gratuite
d'ailleurs sur le protectionnisme je
vais vous dire je suis convaincu que les
français sont les premiers exploitants
de centrales nucléaires sont les
premiers à donner la sécurité et vous ne
ferez pas de l'économie et vous ne serez
pas du développement économique avec des
éoliennes ou avec des des bougies ou des
économies de bouts de chandelle si vous
voulez avoir un pays d'envergure je suis
obligé de vous dire que vous ne pouvez
pas fermer le nucléaire demain matin
même dans vingt ans vous serez obligé de
passer par le nucléaire
ou alors il faut recréer un centre à
donner mais oui d'accord mais aussi à ce
moment-là recréer des centrales
hydroélectriques francs n'en finit plus
on peut revenir au charbon aussi dans le
nucléaire c'est une méthode qui bien
dompté cissé vit mal en sait quelque
chose d'étonnant quand j'ai écouté par
les autres ou que celles exploitées par
des gens qui ne savent pas l'utiliser si
on arrive à des catastrophes
on va voir s'afficher dans quelques
temps vos temps de parole peut-être que
patricia charton je crois savoir un
petit peu de retard si vous souhaitiez
répondre on va enchaîner ça va
s'afficher dans quelques secondes les
temps de parole on va les voir à l'écran
voilà du coup pas tricher on est
quasiment tout le monde est à égalité à
paris bercy un peu d'avancé on poursuit
ce débat où madame charpentier petites
choses je voulais
apporter aussi un élément au débat c'est
que les chercheurs en sociologie on
démontre que d'ici 20 ans 40% des
emplois en moyenne ça peut être 30 % en
europe et 40 pour ce cas en europe de
l'ouest et est un peu un peu plus en
europe de l'est
40% des emplois vont disparaître
pourquoi pourquoi à cause de la
digitalisation parce que on est
aujourd'hui dans un monde numérique et
ce monde numérique va remplacer
énormément d'emplois donc là il faudra
trouver aussi des moyens de réagir et
c'est pas pour les cinq ans à venir
qu'il faut réagir c'est pour bien plus
longtemps ont poursuivi cette émission
avec la deuxième thématique la
moralisation de la vie politique un
projet de loi a été présenté il ya
quelques jours par le ministre de la
justice françois bayrou
l'uci a été globalement jugé
positivement en tout cas par les
commentateurs par la presse si vous avez
été élu député vous serez amené à vous
prononcer dessus d'ici très peu de temps
dès cet été sur deux textes alors
voterez vous pour ou contre celui ci
prévoit notamment la suppression de la
réserve parlementaire c'est un des
points parmi tant d'autres alors voterez
vous pour ou contre
et pourquoi stéphane roussillon
roussillon décidément j'ai du mal
excusez moi mais à chaque fois que le
nom qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran à la
bonne orthographe puisque vous voterez
pour ou contre
et pourquoi j'ai des origines 0 du
roussillon mais j'ai perdu à nouveau le
savez c'est pour ça je permettais mois
cette loi est encore vague il ya
quelques points jugé que j'appellerais
publicitaire s'est tu pour moi une loi
gadget les français la réclame donc
monsieur macron qui aime bien plaire aux
français les endormir va nous pondre une
loi pour pour calmer le gentiment le
peuple aujourd'hui la moralisation de la
vie politique en général
au delà de mettre un flic derrière
chaque député
pour respecter pour voir s'il a des
vraies valeurs de représentation
démocratique
je pense qu'il faudrait
s'attarder respect respecter déjà la
démocratie nous avions une constitution
qui prévoyait de de sanction de deux
crimes crimes votre complot de la sûreté
de l'état et crypte contre trahison de
l'état dans les 20 dernières années
c'est cesser ces points la constitution
ont été totalement supprimée sans l'avis
des français
et au passage comme de fait exprès
depuis 20 ans nous transmettons notre
souveraineté totale à l'union européenne
et nous n'avons plus aucun élément dans
la constitution pour leur reprocher et
le faire payer à nos représentants
je pense que la moindre des choses
serait de respecter la démocratie avant
d'essayer de moraliser élémentaires en
prison quand caisse convainc roi des
menteurs et des voleurs aussi parfois
dans la politique de oui oui justement
c'est à ça que je pense et on a trouvé
un à passer quelques-uns je voudrais pas
donner des noms mais je m'aperçois
qu'ils ont été poursuivis devant les
tribunaux mais personne n'a demandé le
remboursement des sommes détournées
- avant d'augmenter les gens pour tout
le monde je voudrais d'abord qu'on fasse
couvrait la monnaie qui est parti là où
il faut pas par exemple à savez pour
vous et vous verrez vous ou pour celui
qui sait j'ai des costumes la publier
son nom donc ils ne sont qu il faudrait
déjà faire rentrer la mener est celui
qui a détourné ne peut plus jamais se
présenter en qu'une élection dont vous
allez encore pris moi que je vais encore
plus loin et si pour reprendre sur aussi
si il a commis un crime ou si il a
promis des trahisons l'état récemment
l'influent destitué de la nationalité
française
donc vous allez plus loin on l'a compris
patricia charton votre point de vue est
ce que vous le si vous voterez vous ce
texte là à l'assemblée cet été il va
enfin on votera pas ce que j'espère
qu'on sera plusieurs
des verts on votera évidemment c'est
quelque chose qui est dans les gènes de
l'écologie de faire en sorte de ne pas
cumuler les mandats de ne pas faire de
cavalerie non plus puisque on voit très
souvent des députés passée à être mère
puisse et batteur puis et c'est donc
qu'ils enfilent enchaîne les mandats les
uns derrière les autres
après c'est peut-être difficile c'est
vrai de retrouver un vrai travail un
vrai travail
c'est un travail évidemment harassant
j'ai des amis et lui et je sais que
c'est un travail harassant pour ceux qui
travaillent en tout cas et donc vont
évidemment pour moi un projet
san cela ne se décrète pas autour d'une
table et au bar d'un café dans un bar ou
dans un café ça se décrète autour d'une
table de discussion et et selon des
objectifs bien précis et des enjeux donc
on peut on peut ici listées ce qu'on
imagine devoir modifier mais ce qui est
important c'est pas perdre de vue
évidemment la moralisation et non pas
une cette histoire de confiance mais nos
morale réellement jean pierre mercier
pour cette question là ce débat-là
goûter c'est du flan de cette loi c'est
du flan parce que tant que ça sera
l'argent qui gérera la société étant que
ça sera la loi de l'argent il y aura
toujours des corrompus
il ya par contre c'est pas déjà un bon
point bon début même si vous estimez que
ça va passer loin apparemment vous
accordez pas cette chose là en moins
mais je suis d'accord avec mes camarades
de gauche est-ce que vous avez vu ça oui
je suis pas d'extrême droite
on va peut-être laissé parler monsieur
merci sur sur cette problématique gosse
je serais sûrement pas d'accord avec
vous mais il ya des mesures qui sont
essentiels pour lutter pour la
moralisation de la vie la vie politique
la première ça serait que d'imposer à
chaque élu une révocabilité à tout
moment à tout moment il peut être
révocable
voilà la deuxième la deuxième mesure ça
serait d'imposer un salaire maximum qui
tourne autour d'un d'un salaire d'un
ouvrier professionnel par exemple
présents autour de 1800 euros par mois
et je pense qu'ils auraient beaucoup
moins de candidats qui se bousculaient
au portillon pour accéder à la mangeoire
parce que c'est une mangeoire en l'état
actuel est de supprimer l'ensemble des
avantages qui sont liés à cette fonction
de député de sénateur ou de ou des
différents élus et là on y verrait déjà
beaucoup plus clair
des députés qui doivent se déplacer de
l'autre bout de la france
faut bien rembourser leurs frais de
déplacement bah ça peut-être qu'il
faudrait le remplacer laurent pourcel
mais sûrement pas dans un avion en
première classe et et sûrement pas dans
un tgv en première classe mais c'est pas
ça les amis les vrais avantages c'est
pas ça c'est de pouvoir faire travailler
sa famille c'est de pouvoir faire
travailler ses enfants c'est de pouvoir
payer c'est de pouvoir avoir avoir une
voiture gratuit c'est pour avoir le
remboursement dentaire complètement
complètement complètement gratuit c'est
ça l'ensemble des mesures qu'il faudrait
des avantages qu'il faudra supprimer
mais surtout plafonner les indemnités
pour les députés
et puis que ça soit révocable à tout
moment alors stéphane rossi allez-y vous
pouvez réagir sachant que ça vous fera
moins de temps évident que la personne
l'enjeu c'est un point très rapide sur
cette normalisation juste pour dire que
je regrette qu'il ne soit pas prévu a
priori dans la loi que les élus doivent
justifier d'un casier judiciaire vierge
et je tiens à rappeler à préciser nos
téléspectateurs que les 574 candidats
que présente lui perd sur 577
circonscriptions
je crois que c'est un des partis qui se
présentent le plus l'ensemble des
candidats et suppléants ont un casier un
casier judiciaire vierge je pense que
quand on veut donner il faut donner
l'exemple
tous avaient des casiers judiciaires y
avait un peu moins de candidats sont
vides
très bien on a aucune condamnation donc
on va c'est même car tout ça avant de
passer à votre carte blanche à chacun on
va voir les temps de parole je crois
qu'ils se sont rééquilibrés donc bon
point pour vous merci à vous pour ce
débat on va les voir s'afficher dans
quelques instants à l'écran vous
dépasser tous évidemment les cinq
minutes et légèrement un peu d avance
désormais pour madame webber on passe à
la carte blanche qui vous permet
d'exposer le point où la thématique que
vous souhaitez libre à vous de choisir
ce que vous voulez on commence on prend
l'ordre inverse du début d'émission dont
patricia charton pour europe ecologie
les verts
quel est votre carte blanche europe
ecologie les verts
excusez moi mais les filles aussi et
puis voilà alors j'en parlais tout à
l'heure pour moi
le principal c'est c'est une une
alimentation saine donc à commencer
évidemment par par les cantines parce
que c'est quelque chose qui est un
levier fort pour pour transformer
l'agriculture intensive et très
industrialisée d'aujourd'hui pour faire
en sorte que nos enfants mangent
sainement bio parce que on appelle ça
bio aujourd'hui mais c'était une
naturelle de mes grands parents
donc il faut aujourd'hui ddd estampillé
pour savoir qu'on mange autre chose que
du poison
donc c'est déjà cette politique là que
j'aimerais mener au niveau national
faire en sorte que les régions
n'abandonne pas les maraîchers bio
n'abandonne pas non plus les promesses
qu'ils ont faites avant lors de leur
élection et que voilà donc ça c'est la
partie pour l'agriculture et puis aussi
au niveau énergétique
on sait aujourd'hui on est capable de
mettre en place des des fermes solaires
dans le sud des fermes éoliennes là où
il ya du vent de la mama de la marée
motrice etc
on est aussi capable de pouvoir échanger
et partager c'est c'est cette énergie
produite sur l'ensemble du territoire
que ce soit un territoire local ou
ensuite national jean-pierre à merci
votre carte blanche pour lutte ouvrière
écoutez moi le message que je voudrais
délivré c'est quand on est un
travailleur on doit avoir conscience à
l'esprit on voit vraiment il faut avoir
cette idée bien ancrée dans la tête que
c'est pas un bulletin de vote qui peut
faire changer sa vie c'est les luttes
c'est les mobilisations qu'on sera en
capacité de mener ça sera les
manifestations de rue ça sera les
occupations d'entreprises les
occupations d usines ça sera les grèves
pour faire changer notre vie en tant que
travailleur ce gouvernement est un
gouvernement qui a déclaré la guerre à
l'ensemble des travailleurs
il n'y aura pas d'autre solution que de
répondre par un en imposant un rapport
de force suffisamment important pour
faire reculer ce gouvernement faire
reculer macron et faire reculer derrière
tout ce qu'ils sont
les vrais décideurs dans cette société
j'entends les membres des conseils
d'administration de ces grandes
entreprises c'est la famille peugeot
c'est bernard arnault c'est les
bettencourt et compagnie c'est eux qui
font la pluie et le beau temps dans
cette société
et c'est aux travailleurs par leur
mobilisation par leur conscience
politique qu'il faut qu'ils arrivent à
les faire reculer et il y aura pas
d'autre choix que de se mobiliser tous
ensemble y compris la première
mobilisation ça sera contre la loi
macron stéphane rousseau pour le pea
votre carte blanche à vous alors écoutez
le slogan de l'upper et l'union du
peuple pour établir la démocratie dont
j'utiliserai ma carte blanche sur ce
sujet là parce que je pense que avant
tout c'est le premier sujet qu'il faut
rétablir en france c'est rétablir une
vraie démocratie puisque le peuple
puisse s'exprimer j'aimerais évoquer
deux propositions centrale que fait
l'upm est tout d'abord un référendum il
a city that if plus populaires pour
qu'enfin le peuple puisse soumettre les
lois et qu'elles ne soient plus soumis
par les non élus de la commission
européenne et qu'à partir de 500 mille
signatures en mairie toute question puis
peut-être poser à l'ensemble des
français
deuxième point est parce que aujourd'hui
l'abstentionnisme le vote blanc est
néanmoins et personne ne dit assez
souvent le
le premier parti de france un principe
de reconnaissance du vote blanc est un
principe révocatoire partant du principe
que chaque si le vote blanc venait en
tête d'un scrutin quel qu'il soit
l'ensemble des candidats devraient être
les les questions devraient être faites
et l'ensemble des candidats n'ayant pas
répondu à l'attenté majoritaire ddd
français devraient être remplacés pour
qu'enfin nous puissions choisir nos
représentants et qu'ils ne soient pas
imposées par des partis politiques qui
sert des intérêts qui ne sont pas les
nôtres
enfin daniel weber candidate du parti de
la france vous concluez cette émission
nous étions un peu en avance donc un
petit peu moins de temps pour vous mais
allez-y vous avez votre carte blanche
donc moi je veux défendre surtout les
artisans les commerçants les professions
libérales les personnels de santé les
pompiers et surtout de police qui encore
une fois de se faire attaquer sur le
parvis de notre-dame sont ces
fonctionnaires là c'est le désordre dans
la société
donc moi je veux permettre aux parents
de choisir aussi l'école pour leurs
enfants
les cartes scolaires c'est ça ne tient
pas debout innocence je veut diminuer
les allocations les avantages à chacun
par le biais de de l'urssaf des caisses
d'allocations familiales parce que c'est
la seule méthode pour encourager le
travail aujourd'hui on court après les
allocations concours but après un
employeur enfin je voudrais dire oui ces
dernières sont ce que je voulais dire
madame elisabeth badinter mais j'ai pas
le temps de fouiller plus eux mêmes mais
madame elisabeth badinter se plaint que
maintenant les femmes ne peuvent plus
s'habiller comme elles veulent dans
certains quartiers en france et nous
sommes au port république
j'aimerais que
communauté intégriste et compagnie ce
qu'on peut dire merci à vous casser la
fin de ce débat pour la 12ème
circonscription merci aussi aux autres
candidats les cinq premiers vous étiez 9
à être venus ce soir je rappelle que
vous serez 14 dimanche vous retrouvez
d'ailleurs la liste complète des
candidats sur le site internet de tv fil
78 la rédaction espère que ces débats
vous auront aider dans votre choix pour
ce dimanche pensez à voter évidemment et
n'oubliez pas aussi que tv fil 78 2 vous
propose toujours dimanche à partir de
19h30 une soirée spéciale électorale en
direct pour revenir sur les résultats
adam trois jours donc belle soirée à
tous belle soirée à tout
[Musique]